todrick Danny reunited and it feels so
good I missed you I missed you more the
last time I talked to you was on your
set you let me wear gorgeous yellow fur
mosquito you looked better in it than I
did so it was my pleasure no now you're
on my turf style is overalls from
Marshall I love it's cuz you know this
is KBT try to put this on I mean if you
want you first of all this is my first
time at VidCon
mine too is it really well kind of I was
here one time for one performance that
was outside and I only went to that
stage so I'm considering this my
official first VidCon so yeah has anyone
give you any tips on to survive this
crazy weekend with all these people I
don't know I've just kind of gotten
thrown in and it's really really cool no
one gave me any tips and I'm like I'm
from the hood I'm not gonna be scared of
some kids at VidCon it's not gonna
happen I'm down like I will walk into
the jungle no no no this fearless let's
all the well-armed you're torques I know
you're really excited about that that's
coming up yeah so I am going on tour
it's straight out of I'm so excited
about it and it's so crazy I dropped in
my visual album today which is all the
original music that I'm doing on the
tour I have the most amazing friends I
decided to do this about a month and a
half ago I wrote 20 songs we filmed 16
videos in two weeks and last minute I
called so many people and some of my
friends unfortunately couldn't do it but
I have pentatonix is there Jordin Sparks
amber Riley from Glee Joseph
gordon-levitt plays the wizard how did
this come unthe
I have no idea because these people are
behind us and they just believe in me
and I just I I was like getting
emotional every day on set because I was
like I can't believe that you're here
volunteer your time to help me can you
think of summer what's the first thing
that comes to mind when I think of
summer I think of my first true love
which I also sing about in my album I'm
not just plugging this because of that
but I had so much fun I worked at Six
Flags Over Texas that was my first job
when I was 16 and I did the shows there
so we did shows six days a week
and it was just so much fun and it was
the first time I felt comfortable
telling people who I really was it was a
cast full of amazingly talented people
it was just like the best summer
I loved it I can't wait to see the show
and I see everything about you is
positive and loving and just a hell of a
lot of fun thank you so much to you I
know right exactly I can't wait to watch
the visual album so I got a gonna go
watch that
enjoy your okay